[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous ses
sens public votre rendez vous quotidien
de débats de reportages et des
expertises sur public sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité pour
décortiquer aussi les grandes mutations
de notre société et l'actualité de ce 8
septembre ce sont les inquiétudes
en grande bretagne la reine a été placé
sous surveillance médicale la famille
royale est en train de se regrouper au
château de balmoral soixante dix ans de
règne c'est une mémoire du siècle c'est
aussi une figure le symbole qui cimente
la grande bretagne et son éventuelle
disparition serait un séisme on va
tenter de mesurer l'ondé de choc avec
mes invités et puis pour notre second
débat c'est la stratégie diplomatique
des mâles macron que vous propose
d'analyser pourquoi at il maintenu un
lien avec vladimir poutine après
l'invasion de l'ukraine quelle est la
place de la france dans un nouvel ordre
mondial dominé par le bras de fer entre
la chine et les etats unis comme en
europe mais son unité à l'épreuve depuis
six mois réponse de nos experts tout à
l'heure mais d'abord le récit de cet
après midi où le regard des anglais puis
du monde entier s'est tourné vers le
château de balmoral flora sauvage le
royaume uni retient son souffle en début
d'après midi le palais de buckingham a
indiqué que les médecins de la reine
elizabeth ii ont recommandé qu'elle soit
placée sous surveillance médicale son
héritier charles et ses trois autres
enfants sont à son chevet à balmoral en
écosse ses petits fils william et harry
sont aussi attendus sur place il ya deux
jours la reine elizabeth ii a rencontré
la nouvelle première ministre us à
balmoral en raison de ses problèmes de
santé elle est alors apparue fragile
dans un tweet la première ministre a
exprimé sa sympathie à la famille royale
âgée de 96 ans la monarque à la
longévité record jouit d'une immense
popularité au royaume uni depuis son
accès au trône à l'âge de 25 ans
selon le protocole à son décès le pays
entrera dans une période de deuil
national
douze jours
pour évoquer donc le destin de
l'angleterre en ces heures d'incertitude
autour de la santé de la reine elizabeth
ii j'accueille patricia allemonière
bonsoir patricia bienvenue vous êtes
grand reporter spécialiste des relations
internationales vous avez été
correspondante à londres pendant
plusieurs années bruno cautrès
politologue bonsoir bruno bienvenue
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof titulaire
d'un doctorat franco-britannique vous
avez vécu en angleterre vous connaissez
bien son architecture politique et et
sociétal que également richard wehrli
correspondant au journal le temps
bonsoir richard observateurs affûté de
l'actualité européenne et letifi accrue
pas éditorialiste politique devant soi
laetitia merci d'être là vaut aussi la
reine d'angleterre âgé donc de 96 ans ce
n'est pas une surprise à cet âge là on
peut dire ça comme ça de l'avoir placé
sous surveillance médicale mais voir la
famille royale se regrouper à balmoral à
son chevet patricia allemonière vous qui
connaissez bien les codes
notamment des médias britanniques c'est
un signe peut être d'une crise plus
grave que les autres ah oui
définitivement d'ailleurs on a on a tout
de suite compris l'ampleur de la crise à
deux signent un la bbc a très vite dit
qu'elle laissait ces images accessibles
au monde entier et là c'est vraiment
ainsi une scène ça ne se passe
pratiquement jamais deuxièmement oui tu
rêves pratiquement il faut que des
événements traits majeurs ou alors après
ces désaccords mais là c'est une
décision de la bbc et puis deuxième
signe important et bien c'est le
parlement la session était cet arrêté
est donc là encore ces deux signes qui
montrent et il savait ce pays marche
beaucoup enfin fonctionne beaucoup sur
tout ce qui est signe symbole on a aussi
appris que la relève de demain seraient
changés modifier la garde à la gare le
ou oui la reine était très attaché à
tous ces codes elle est l'aînée
pratiquement dans cet univers et elle
connaissait très bien les médias leur
fonctionnement n'oubliez pas que l a
tenu tout de suite à faire participer la
télévision à toutes les toutes les
opérations au grand dam des premiers
ministres de l'époque et donc
le pays aujourd'hui à l'heure où on
parle il est ensuite elle a exactement
il est ensuite il a vu ses il est en
suspens oui alors on va évoquer
effectivement l'impact mondial aussi
d'un événement comme celui là même
parce que parce que la reine
d'angleterre voilà c'est une mémoire du
siècle je les dis en titre et bruno
cautrès elle était quasi absente de son
jubilé pour les 70 ans de règne c'était
tôt au début du mois de juin là aussi
pour les anglais c'était peut-être un
mauvais signe qu'est ce qu'elle
représente pour les citoyens
britanniques la reine d'angleterre leur
souverain et c'est une dimension du
royaume unique est très importante en
fait et c'est vrai que pour les français
en particulier c'est toujours un peu
étrange
c'est une monarchie le royaume uni une
monarchie constitutionnelle et à un
premier ministre mais elle représente
d'abord et avant tout le souverain le
chef de l'état elle est le chef de
l'état elle est aussi chef de l'église
anglicane donc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est quelque
chose que nous les français nous ont du
mal à comprendre que chef de l'état
puisse en même temps le chef d'une
église bas c'est le cas c'est
effectivement dont quelque chose de
absolument fondamental dans la vie du
royaume uni et même si l'image de la
reine d'angleterre pourrait prêter à
sourire avec l'idée qu'elle inaugure des
chrysanthèmes pas du tout non non elle a
des fonctions quand même qu'ils sont
importantes et à des actes de la reine
qui sont importants ce n'est pas que du
symbole elle aussi du pouvoir le premier
ministre est bien vient se présenter
devant la reine d'angleterre avant
d'aller aux communes avant ils vont les
représenter devant
donc des pouvoirs qui sont symboliques
mais aussi des pouvoirs qui sont
importants toutes les études d'opinion
montrent d'ailleurs que l'attachement
des britanniques à la couronne restent
importants même s'il ya eu beaucoup de
difficultés depuis une vingtaine
d'années on va dire du point de vue de
l'image de la monarchie britannique donc
les dernières enquêtes sur garder avant
de venir continue de montrer un soutien
populaire assez important avec plus de
britanniques qui disent que le royaume
uni ce portrait plus mal s'il n'y avait
pas la monarchie est beaucoup plus que
ceux qui voudraient abolir la monarchie
le sentiment républicain
au royaume uni n'est pas le sentiment
dominant est alors ce sera intéressant
on l'évoquera un peu plus tard dans ce
débat de voir si ça pourrait changer
avec un une autre personne le successeur
de la reine d'angleterre
comme souverain de dieu du royaume
britannique richard wehrli je disais 70
ans de règne mémoire du siècle vous
vouliez insisté sur un autre aspect
l'aspect européen pourquoi oui parce que
d'abord par la durée de son règne qui
nous ramène directement à quoi à la
seconde guerre mondiale sophie lesne
l'originalité est vraiment de la reine
elizabeth s'est calé ce lien entre le
plus grand séisme qui est traumatisé le
continent asseoir la seconde guerre
mondiale et notre époque moderne et je
crois que ça ça reste moins pour avoir
été correspondant dans en dehors de
l'europe notamment en asie je peux vous
dire que vu d'asie c'est la reine
européenne elle symbolise beaucoup plus
par exemple que la reine de hollande
beaucoup plus que les monarchies
scandinaves ce qu'est l'europe en termes
de tradition en terme d'histoire et ça
je crois que c'est quelque chose qu'elle
va emporter avec elle parce que personne
après elle ne pourra ne pourra avoir cet
héritage là et par ailleurs elle a
toujours su extrêmement bien leur
présentait d'ailleurs vous aurez noté
que à la différence du royaume uni où le
sentiment républicain n'a pas augmenté
dans des pays lointains comme
l'australie comme le canada en revanche
les républicains ont pris de
l'importance parce que justement il ne
s'en sentait plus représentée par cette
haine en tout cas une partie de la
population alors que ces pays font
toujours partie à l'ordre les chefs
d'état si je ne me trompe pas de
l'australie de la nouvelle zélande et du
canada et donc c'est encore son portrait
sur les pièces de monnaie enfin c'est ce
paradoxe là dont on parle aussi mais je
crois que c'est dimension européenne
restera alors il ya cette grande
interrogation peut-être qu'elle l'ait
peut-être qu'elle a laissé une trace
écrite sera trop un jour si elle était
pour ou contre le brésil beaucoup a été
écrit là-dessus on le sera sans doute
pas ça restera le grand mystère mais je
crois que cette dimension européenne
elle symbolise l europe les traumatismes
de l'europe et aussi le formidable
rebond qui a été celui de l'europe après
la seconde est ce que vous êtes
forcément d'accord avec cette dimension
là c'était parce qu'il se serait venu en
premier à votre esprit patricia les
modèles n ont pas dire pas du tout là je
veux dire c'est vrai que parce que je
pense que vous avez un regard hors
européen pratiquement que vous que vous
l'apercevez percevez comme tel la reine
c'est toujours bien gardée effectivement
de se positionner et sur toutes les
questions questions politiques elle
voulait incarner le commonwealth c'est
ce qu'elle a voulu faire si elle fait
battu pour que pour le commonwealth
perdure je crois que sans son combat le
commonwealth ce serait complètement
étiolé et donc l'europe s'était pas
assez ne crois pas que c'était vraiment
son son sujet son sujet c'était quand
même l'empiré britannique le
commonwealth et elle voulait absolument
que son fils charles
porte cette charge ne crois pas que
charge soit aussi à lens que sur cette
question que sa maman on peut le dire on
peut l'appeler comme sa maman et je ne
pense pas plus que la pression ne sais
pas je ne suis pas dans le secret des
dieux mais bon même si mes shop sera
différent parce qu'on va sûrement en
parler parce que lui se prononce sur
tout il se prononce sur les questions
économiques qui se prononce sur les
questions environnementales
comme vous l'avez fait remarquer la
reine a tout fait pour rester très
discrète sur toutes ces questions
ce n'était pas son job et donc je pense
qu'on va voir là un changement
d'ailleurs sa méthode de communication
qui est participe aussi de sa légende
elle n'a donné aucune interview depuis
son accession au trône alors elle se
laisse filmer elle s'est laissée
photographier par les plus grands
on a l'habitude de la voir par exemple à
cheval un sa balade quotidienne
participe au sida légende et puis elle
envoie des messages avec ses tenues vous
parliez justement de son penchant ou pas
pour le prg excitant tout cas lors d'un
discours au parlement elle était apparue
avec un chapeau aux couleurs européennes
et des étoiles il y avait le nom il y
avait le bon nombre d'états on y voyait
le même nombre des poils drapeaux bleus
avec deux fleurs au coeur jaune qui
rappelait évidemment les couleurs de
l'europe en plein après xi donc c'est sa
façon de communiquer c'est une façon
très originale par par l'image mais
c'est intéressant bruno cautrès parce
que si on analyse la sa place dans la
société britannique et le on va dire le
positionnement toujours particulier un
peu décalée des anglais même quand il
était dans l'europe ça peut sembler
étonnante de dire que la reine
d'angleterre est un symbole de l'europe
voyez ce que je veux dire est qu'elle ne
s'est jamais vraiment exprimé sur le
sujet bien que exerçant ses fonctions de
chef d'état donc étant présente lorsque
des chefs d'état européens viennent au
royaume uni évidemment on a beaucoup
d'image en france en particulier nos
présidents de la république qui ont été
accueillis par la reine d'angleterre qui
ont qui ont effectivement participé à
tout le cérémonial de ce point de vue là
mais c'est vrai que ça reste une
monarchie mais constitutionnel et c'est
le premier ministre qui est en charge de
conduire évidemment la politique du
royaume uni en matière européenne à 1
c'est vrai qu'on avait tous remarqué ce
symbole du chapeau qui avait quand même
été un message qui était qui était qui
était adressé
elle a dans certains discours ventes et
des dimensions européennes par exemple
quand nous avons inauguré le tunnel sous
la manche de ce point de vue là c'est
vrai que c'est à la fois un symbole et
elle s'était exprimé en disant que le
feu s'était uniquement réunissant des
pays européens qu'on pouvait avoir
quelque chose d'aussi d'aussi grands
donc sans jamais s'exprimer clairement
sur le sujet le sujet de l'europe d'art
noter comme le royaume uni ou l'opinion
publique était fortement opposée à
l'europe
c'est vrai qu'elle n'a jamais non plus
pris de positions qui étaient des
positions clairement eurosceptiques
clairement alors c'est vrai que du point
de vue
du du rapport du royaume uni par rapport
à la question la question européenne
c'était évidemment quelque chose de très
très sensible pour elle de venir sur ce
sur ce sujet et il ya de ce point de vue
là quand même avant tout un rôle de
souverain qui représente le pays alors
j'ajouterais aussi effectivement sur ses
dimensions de commonwealth que tout le
monde a souligné c'est une dimension qui
est fondamental dont le royaume uni qui
est quelque chose que du point de vue du
vue de la france on perçoit on perçoit
assez mal à quelqu'un trop si c'est
la cosmétique
dans la vie du royaume uni je dis
souvent je
il m'arrive de poser à mes études à
sciences po la question de serment après
vos études qu'est ce que vous faites ou
est-ce que vous allez travailler j'ai
jamais aimé étions pratiquement qui me
dit je suis allé travailler par exemple
dans les pays de l'afrique francophone
par contre au royaume uni chez rencontré
beaucoup de jeunes étudiants qui ont
vite aller travailler dans l'épée du
commun parce que vous disiez qu'elle
incarnait le commonwealth aujourd'hui
vous avez raison qu'est ce que signifie
le commonwealth et d'élire à ce que ce
sont des échanges commerciaux comment on
peut définir byron sonne comme si la
tunisie libre exit miser beaucoup sur
les dettes d'hier mais nous on a on a la
solution à ses débouchés
sociaux la décolonisation s'est fait
totalement différente de la nôtre avec
l'instauration de liens très économique
intense avec les autres pays laissant
totalement les pays indépendants se
rassurent sur un plan que dis je
rajouterais juste un tout petit point
c'est que vous publiez que la famille
royale par rapport à l'europe justement
est originaire de revient sur absolue et
ça c'est très important pour comprendre
parfois les critiques en grande bretagne
de la famille royale est aussi son
attachement aux terres européennes la
dina l'info pardon je vous interromps au
chara l'instant l' agence france presse
qui nous apprend que le prince william
arrive à balmoral avec plusieurs autres
membres de la famille royale britannique
évidemment tout cela est suivie et en
direct par les médias britanniques comme
on peut l'imaginer jour il atteint ainsi
les windsor est donc lié à l'allemagne à
l'origine est par ailleurs la reine
elizabeth et est mariée au prince philip
de grèce qui est décédé il y a
maintenant je crois deux ou trois ans ou
peut-être un petit peu plus mais une
chose que je voulais que je voulais
rajouter c'est qu'il y à une ironie
assez tragique c'est que si elle devait
disparaître elle disparaît un moment où
le royaume est désunie le royaume uni
est désunie on pense évidemment à
l'école les relations semble-t-il entre
la cheffe du gouvernement écossais et la
nouvelle première ministre britannique
sont presque détestable ou en tout cas
très mauvaise alors qu'elle était très
bonne avec la reine et donc c'est vrai
que son départ va laisser non seulement
beaucoup de questions au commonwealth on
l'a dit mais à l'intérieur même du
royaume uni parce que sans doute que on
est coach je ne suis pas assez familier
de la médiation mais j'imagine que ce
qui relie aussi les cosses au
royaume-uni c'était la personnalité de
la reine est que l disparu les choses
vont peut-être se présenter autrement
alors j'aimerais qu'on ouvre on viendra
aux conséquences d'un éventuel une
éventuelle disparition de de la reine
mais quand on parle de d'elizabeth ii on
a aussi envie d'ouvrir le livre
d'histoire bon je vous propose d'écouter
d'abord une réaction des manuels mâcon
c'était à l'occasion de ce jubilé des
soixante dix ans donc début juin il il
envoie via les réseaux sociaux les
médias sociaux un message à l'arrêt aime
regarder
depuis les jours sombres ou votre
famille a accueilli le général de gaulle
chez vous jusqu'à la joie de ce dernier
de vous accueillir chez lui vous avez
été une présence constante et une source
de sagesse pour les dirigeants de nos
deux pays
alors il ya il ya effectivement bono co
13 cette date de 1940 vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure qui est majeur dans le
lien entre la france et la grande
bretagne qui ça va vous ouvrir cette
question pour aussi peut-être rappeler
un peu quel a été le rôle de d'elisabeth
pour les environs par beaucoup de
churchill mais dans cette période où il
faut se souvenir que dans la première
année de la guerre entre 40 et 41 quand
churchill arrive au pouvoir il ya des
bombardements mais permanent quotidien
de londres de toutes les grandes villes
britanniques et et voilà il ya le
symbole de la liberté c'est aussi
elisabeth qui n'est pas encore couronné
mais dont on sait qu'elle va devenir
reine oui c'est vrai que cette période
est une période non seulement qui va
cristalliser des choses dans les
relations entre les deux des deux pays
mais aussi du point de vue du rapport
spécifique du royaume uni par rapport à
la question européenne puisque beaucoup
de britanniques dit mais nous on a sauvé
l'europe on nous dit on est on est anti
européens en un panneau en masse au v
laurent puisque nous nous avons résisté
nous n'avons pas été envahi non
seulement nous n'avons pas été enlevée
mais nous avons été la grande plate
forme d'organisation du débarquement et
donc c'est vrai que c'est une date qui
reste très important dans l'imaginaire
collectif des deux pays en particulier
c'est vrai que en france à travers
le général de gaulle ça reste quelque
chose qui est effectivement très très
très important dans l'histoire des deux
pays qui régulièrement évoquée tant du
côté français que du côté britannique à
propos des relations entre les deux pays
et c'est vrai que les relations entre
les deux pays c'est c'est quelque chose
d'assez fascinant les deux pays
partagent beaucoup du polder structures
socio-économiques mes collègues
sociologue qui travaillent sur qu'est ce
qui différencie les pays européens
disent que rien n'est plus proche que la
france et le royaume uni du point de vue
des grands traits sociologique et
socio-économiques
mes collègues dit c'est le noyau dur au
fond du modèle européen
d'organisations socio économiques et de
et de grandes inégalités sociales en en
europe et ces deux structures
socio-économiques ont généré des
systèmes politiques extrêmement
différents c'est assez c'est une
histoire assez fascinante alors je sais
qu'il ya une crispation des manuels
macron là il ya quelques jours un fin
août quand la nouvelle première ministre
avait botté en touche quand on lui avait
demandé à ses amis ou ennemis et un ami
ou un ennemi et puis ensuite il avait
bien rappelé emmanuel macron que parler
d' ennemi enfin en tout cas a botté en
touche de cette façon là était une faute
diplomatique 1 et que les deux pays
étaient liés de façon historique et
quasi quasi traditionnelle c'est une
diplomatie il faut pas toucher on peut
pas toucher à 7 allez on continue de
feuilleter comme ça se
livres d'histoire 70 ans de règne résumé
évidemment beaucoup trop vite par contre
un call mais
voici l'une des dernières apparitions
publiques d'elizabeth ii en juin dernier
la famille royale et tout le royaume uni
célébrait alors ses 70 ans de règne un
jubilé de platine points record de
longévité d'un monarque britannique en
1952 à la suite du décès de son père le
roi george 6 est à tout juste 25 ans la
princesse elisabeth devient alors la
reine elizabeth 2 elle aura vu défiler
pas moins de quinze premiers ministres
de winston churchill au milieu du xxème
siècle ali strauss kahn a rencontré
mardi dernier depuis le début de son
règne et il avait 2 est très populaire
au royaume uni lui britannique sur dix
disent apprécier l'action de leur reine
et ce malgré des périodes plus sombres
comme après la mort de la princesse
diana en 1997 la reine a attendu cinq
jours pour s'exprimer publiquement
expliquant avoir voulu protéger ses
petits enfants une attitude que la
population lui alors reproché l'histoire
de la reine d'angleterre est aussi
intimement liée à celle de son mari le
prince philip celui qu'elle considérait
comme son rock et son soutien il l'a
accompagné et conseillé tout au long de
leurs 70 ans de vie commune la reine
avait fait ses adieux à son époux en
avril 2021 le prince charles est
l'héritier du trône déjà au printemps
dernier il avait remplacé sa mère dont
l'état de santé était déjà dégradée
à les y siègeraient conviennent ensemble
sur une date évidemment très
particulière celle du couronnement
d'elizabeth ii on est le 2 juin 1953 sa
marque aussi une date dans l'essor de la
télévision oui dans l'histoire
politico-médiatique finalement de nos
sociétés occidentales c'est la première
fois que des caméras peuvent filmer
cette cérémonie qui est quand même une
cérémonie religieuse donc il y à 50
caméras 20 caméras installées dans
westminster il ya sur place 2000
journalistes 500 photographes de 92
nationalités différentes et c'est
diffusé en direct par la bbc vous avez
tout à fait raison la reine finalement à
double d'une certaine manière la bbc et
fait entrer la télévision dans
l'exercice du pouvoir et donc il y a aux
etats-unis par exemple 85 millions de
téléspectateurs au royaume uni en grande
bretagne par dont 20 millions alors
qu'il y a que 2 7 millions de postes de
télé vous donc vous imaginez toutes les
familles réunies pour regarder en direct
cette cet événement il ya un film
ensuite en couleur qui sera diffusée par
la gomme au en france un million de
spectateurs dans les salles de cinéma
est un film en noir et blanc qui
traverse l'atlantique pour être diffusée
au canada et en australie et en
nouvelle-zélande et au delà
et au delà de on va dire de la prouesse
un peu technique technologique il ya
aussi des enjeux géopolitiques avec la
retransmission de ce couronnement oui
déjà pas en politique intérieure c'est
vrai qu'elle arrête quand même un peu
bousculé un set rennes ne s'est pas du
tout elle qui normalement doit être sur
le trône c'est son père qui décède et
puis après l'habitation de son oncle
sulfureux douar 8 donc elle arrive elle
a quand même une responsabilité à 25 ans
sur les épaules et puis c'est vrai qu'en
politique extérieure on est où il avait
dit dans dans la foulée de la fin de la
de la deuxième guerre mondiale on est en
53 le royaume a perdu l'inde donc il
faut que la monarchie britannique
démontre encore une fois qu'elle est
puissante et qu'elle pèse sur la scène
géopolitique et donc il y aura 16 mois
de préparatifs thomas et de répétitions
pour qu'il n'y ait aucun faux pas c'est
la première fois que la monarchie décide
de se servir de la télévision elle a
appris son métier draine finalement les
jeunes patricia allemonière elle a pris
mais elle a très bien appris
c'était pratiquement un sans-faute je
pense jusqu'à là ce qu'on a appelé un
peu la crise de la monarchie dans les
années 90 est là et là ça a dérapé c'est
vrai qu' une succession d'événements il
ya eu un incendie de balme de balmoral
il ya eu un incendie il ya eu après la
crise autour des revenus de la famille
royale est donc dans ces années 91 92 93
après huldaï année 10 10 la mort de lady
di mal géré aussi là on a senti un
flottement le mouvement dont vous
parliez république à la pris un peu de
l'ampleur mais qu'il eut des critiques
est là et la b2 qui savait
merveilleusement bien jouer de la presse
qu ici qui avait complètement organisée
avec des spéciales spécialistes au tout
est bien là ça dérape et ça a mal géré
et donc une contestation très forte très
forte dans durant cette période là de la
monarchie et après c'est reparti oui
alors c'est le château de windsor la
banque avait qui avait brûlé ya aucun
souci mais c'était c'était wilson à côté
de londres bruno cautrès vous étiez
à londres au moment de la mort de lady
diana c'est intéressant de que vous nous
racontiez comment les les commentateurs
les journalistes britanniques que vous
pouviez côtoyé ont réagi je suivais
oxford à l'époque mais j'ai été à
londres on va voir de vraiment qu'est ce
que c'est que ce qu'est ce que c'était
parce que c'était tellement
impressionnant et effectivement la
réaction est une réaction qui est au
delà de ce qu'on pourra voir un jour en
france aucun de chefs d'état ne décède
en
aura un jour un événement de ce serait
un tel impact avec les correspondants
royaux qui sont des journalistes
spécialisés peut-être qu'on en connaît
pas on n'a pas nous vraiment de
correspondants qui ne font que l'élysée
royaume en larmes en direct en larmes et
ont tous le costume sombre la cravate
noire en larmes pendant de nombreuses
heures effectivement quelque chose qui
était extrêmement spectrem en
spectaculaire puisque c'était une icône
l'un des éléments de communication
vraiment assez assez incroyable qui sait
qui c'est passé dans les heures qui ont
suivi a été l'arrivée de tony blair dans
sa circonscription
il est aller à la messe
tony blair et devant devant l'église où
il se rendait il y avait comme par
hasard des micros qui étaient là et où
tony blair dont on connaît le talent de
communication à l'époque à cette
expression qui va beaucoup marqué qui va
être un marqueur de cette période la
princesse du peuple
voilà il avait compris donc un acte de
communication extrêmement important qui
pose un mot très important sur le sur le
sentiment et derrière effectivement 7,7
ce pays entièrement en deuil
de manière comme je crois je n'avais
jamais vu un événement si aussi
considérable les les legends accumulant
les bouquets de fleurs
devant
devant tous les bâtiments publics et en
particulier devant le château de la
reine
doit filtrer extrêmement impressionnant
et j'ai souvenir par exemple d'avoir
pris un bus qui allait de oxford à
londres pour aller voir ce qui ce qui se
passait et j'ai fait une faute de goût
impardonnable
puisque ce but j'étais prague peut-être
le seul dans le bus à ne pas avoir de
bouquets de fleurs avec moi les gens
venaient tous pour déposer un bouquet de
fleurs devant buckingham mais pour
reconnaissez que la reine dans toute
cette période
bienvenue sur wii je voudrais bien vous
entendre là dessus richard berry parce
que c'est peut-être une des rares fois
où isabelle doha était en décalage avec
avec l'opinion de son pays on l'a on la
juge est distante froide face à cet
événement face à la mort de lady jaye
bon d'abord parce qu'il y avait une
grande différence avec d'autres
séquences c'est que celle ci elle était
le résultat d'un accident il y avait une
vitesse nouvelles des médias que
visiblement elisabeth n'avait pas
apprivoiser que la reine elisabeth
n'avait pas apprivoiser elle avait
l'habitude jusqu'à présent laetitia l'a
bien rappelé de cérémonie qui était
préparé
voire très préparé là on était dans un
tout autre registre il fallait réagir
immédiatement et il fallait en plus
réagir à des mots très forts qui étaient
ceux de tony blair puis il ya quand même
alors là ça va nous amener à parler de
la famille royale britannique
c'est tout sauf un sérail familiale
souriant sympathique où tout le monde
s'aime etc il faut pas oublier qu'à
l'époque bien évidemment aucun d'entre
nous ne ne connaisse à 1,1 à des
informations absolument exclusif mais
visiblement si la princesse diana avec
beaucoup de problèmes avec cette famille
le prince charles lui même avait quelque
chose de différent secret à cacher sa
mère n'était pas nécessairement très
très ravi de son comportement non je
dirais elle a aussi été très très forte
dans cet art de conserver la famille
unie malgré tout y compris plus
récemment avec la sphère du prince harry
qui est parti aux états unis mais qui
quand même ne s'est pas séparé de cette
famille il en est un peu l'élément
trublion mais ils restent attachés à
cette famille est semble-t-il la reine
elizabeth a toujours tenu à ce qu'il
reste attaché à la famille elle est
attachée je pense à arrimer je pense que
les anglais on ou voulu à la halle à
cette époque c'était aussi très souvent
en angleterre et je venais juste de
quitter londres en poste ils auront
beaucoup voulu il sortait d'une période
de disputes abominable ce qui s'est
passé ce qui était étalé après ce même
j'ai honte j'aurais honte d'en parler
entre les histoires d'entre charles et
camille en face était il gay charles
était avec camille à cette époque jean
alors je reviens au point central même
si effectivement l'attitude de la reine
à l'époque était intéressante à analyser
pour parler de la ddt du symbole du
pouvoir qu'elle représente et peut-être
aussi 2 de sa représentation de son rôle
de représentation je propose à terme
traduit de nous rejoindre sur sur le
plateau évidemment elle représentait en
tant que chef de l'état le le royaume
uni dans de nombreuses bon soir
événements internationaux et notamment
en france avec une dernière visite qui
date de 2014 oui une visite comme toutes
les visites d'elizabeth ii qui était
historique en france qui venait célébrer
d'autres moments fondamentaux de
l'histoire franco britanniques et même
de l'histoire mondiale on peut dire
puisque en 2014 la reine est l'invité
d'honneur des célébrations du 70e
anniversaire du débarquement pendant
trois jours elle participe à toutes les
commémorations à paris elle ravive la
flamme du soldat inconnu sous l'arc de
triomphe et plus elle assiste aux
cérémonies des cérémonies titanesque on
se le rappelle organisé dans le calvados
avec pas moins de dix neuf chefs d'état
et de gouvernement sur la plage de
ouistreham
l'occasion aussi pour la reine de
rappeler les liens qui unissent le
royaume uni et la france on écoute je me
rappelle le plaisir que j'ai eu à
découvrir ce beau pays pour la première
fois et à cultiver à mon tour une grande
affection pour le peuple français
où qu'il soit lorsqu'ils se rencontrent
nos compatriotes retrouve toujours ce
mélange unique
d'amitié de rivalités dans la bonne
humeur
ainsi que l'admiration qui constitue
l'essence des liens qui unissent la
grande bretagne et la france alors en
français en plus la reine c'est donc
notamment référence bien sûr à la place
des britanniques dans les forces alliées
dans la libération de la france dans son
discours mais aussi à l'histoire franco
britannique qui est on le sait est
parfois tumultueux et auparavant il ya
eu une autre visite d'elizabeth ii qui a
particulièrement marqué les
parlementaires s'étaient dix ans
auparavant et oui 2004 la reine
elizabeth ii se rend en france c'est sa
quatrième visite d'état elle vient
commémorer un autre épisode de
l'histoire commune franco britannique
celui de l'otan de cordiale un accord
qui a été destinée à aplanir les
différends au coloniaux qui a eu entre
le royaume uni et la france et qui a
ensuite servi de base à l'alliance qui a
lié la france et le royaume uni tout au
long du xxème siècle et c'est l'occasion
pour la reine de se rendre au sénat et
de faire un discours dans un contexte un
contexte de grande tension qui est lié a
alors reçu français de participer à la
guerre en irak on écoute cet
anniversaire donne un sens particulier à
ma visite est à la quatrième que j'ai
effectué en france
pour revenir en arrière il est
l'occasion de célébrer la clairvoyance
d'un accord qui allait jeter les bases
d'une alliance décisive qui aura permis
à nos deux pays de traverser les
turbulences du xxème siècle
pour se tourner vers l'avenir
il nous donne à la fois l'occasion de
remy j détention nous avons connus
récemment
et de répondre aux défis et aux
promesses don sera fait demain une
visite qui a bien sûr laissé un souvenir
particulier aux parlementaires un
souvenir inoubliable puisqu'elle s'était
rendu au sénat public sénat à l'époque
avait d'ailleurs mobilisé ses antennes
pour une visite au cordeau orchestrée au
millimètre on voit sur les images à
l'époque christian poncelet président du
sénat jean louis debré président lui
l'assemblée la reine est entré dans la
cour d'honneur dans sa robe elle passa
en revue la garde républicaine et pied
on le voit la garde républicaine à
cheval voilà pour le décor à mais dans
son discours la reine rend aussi hommage
au parlement on écoute
notre attachement mutuel à la démocratie
parlementaire et le socle de notre
liberté et de nos valeurs communes
la liberté ea le plus précieux que nous
ayons
or elle n'est jamais acquise
les liens que nos deux parlements
entretiennent de longue date
non il appelait pu se retenir le
périmètre que les deux parties
souhaitant leur donner
les palmes on continue de jouer un rôle
immense
non seulement à l'échelle nationale mais
aussi dans l'édification de leur offre
et demain voilà comme quoi la monarchie
le parlement peuvent être parfois les
meilleurs alliés merci beaucoup tant
pour ce retour en arrière voilà je le
disais c'est aussi l'occasion cette
émission de feuilleter le livre
d'histoire
ces visites bruno cautrès on voit le on
voit le décorum et moi je voudrais qu'on
assiste ensemble un peu ensemble sur le
rôle politique de la reine d'angleterre
elizabeth ii notamment auprès des
premiers ministres britanniques que je
vous propose de lire ce ce tweet de la
nouvelle première ministre britannique
lys 3 qui dit en cette fin d'après midi
tout notre pays sera profondément
préoccupé par les nouvelles en
provenance de buckingham palace ce midi
mais pensez celle de tous les habitants
du royaume uni vont à sa majesté la
reine et à sa famille en ce moment on
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure bono liste
run est allé alors en l'occurrence à
balmoral puisque
l'état de santé de la reine ne
permettait pas de se fasse ailleurs pour
être en quelque sorte intronisé
j'emploie ce terme qui n'est peut-être
pas le terme exact mais en tout cas ça
nous dit bien le cérémonial est
l'importance de ce rendez vous entre la
reine et les premiers ministres parce
que depuis churchill à vue elle en a vu
beaucoup est-ce qu'elle l'ait pouvait
déconseillé ce qu'elle avait quand même
un rôle politique dans ses prises de
parole publiques on a bien compris qu'il
ya une forme de neutralité obligatoire
mais dans l'intimité d'un d'un bureau à
buckingham c'est autre chose il y a eu
quelques épisodes d'opposition entre la
haine et des premiers ministres
il y en a eu un jour sur une nomination
d'évêques puisque la reine nomme les
évêques de l'église anglicane sur
proposition du premier ministre et
l'élégance veut que le premier ministre
lui donne deux noms n ont choisi qu'un
et que le premier ministre lui donne
dans l'ordre de priorité du premier
ministre et une fois la reine à
l'inversé cet ordre ce qui a créé
beaucoup de tumulte on va dire mais
comment vous le savez c'est un ami clos
ont été portés à la connaissance
mais c'est vrai le faire il faut jamais
oublier que effectivement si le premier
se dissoudre et provoquer des élections
anticipées il doit en venir le demander
à la reine effectivement elle prononce
un discours du trône qui est toujours
tout à fait étonnant puisque la reine va
lire le programme d'action du
gouvernement en disant mon goût ernement
notamment cette fameuse expression mon
gouvernement elle lit ce discours dans
que ce sont des rails et parfois ce
discours une maison il peut sembler loin
de
je sais pas on en est réduit à décoder
les des signes de l'attitude etc mais il
ya certains discours notamment je pense
dans l'époque récente avec boris johnson
où on se disait comment la reine
peut-être dire des choses
comme celle-là oui ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'ils étaient obligés c'est le
chômage et la constitution voilà tout à
fait alors elle est pas vraiment de
constitution value8 mêlée même baissé en
fusion s'est effectivement les les
traditions elle ne peut pas échapper à
ceux là peuvent échapper à ce rôle et
c'est vrai que on a peu d'informations
de ce point de vue là sur comment la
reine at elle pu éventuellement modifier
ou donner un avis sur ce discours il ya
deux ans grâce sans aucun doute beaucoup
de beaucoup de temps on va dire de de
diplomatie au moment où ce discours élus
au ce moment le discours remis par le
premier ministre puisqu'on parle des
qualités politiques de la reine
d'angleterre patricia allemonière il ya
une anecdote que je pensais vraiment
intéressante à à partager avec nos
téléspectateurs qui concerne quads et
des réceptions en 7 et sa capacité à se
souvenir des personnes qu'elle a déjà
croisé parfois longtemps auparavant oui
ce qu'est ce qui est étonnant c'est que
dans tout ce qu'on voit de là comme
image quand elle parle à la s'adresse à
large audience
on va toujours que son visage est assez
ferme est assez calme et son point fort
finalement ne pas laisser transcrit
passer passer ses émotions alors que
dans le privé finalement si on peut
appeler ça le privé ayez une caisse
qu'on parle de réception centaine de
personnes puis centaines de personnes
mais y'a la garden party où elle à sa
tante et elle reçoit les familles disons
j'ai envie d'un proche du gouvernement
il est au corps de l'état et donc j'ai
des amis que la chance de pouvoir faire
partie participer à cette garden party
et en particulier il y avait parmi ses
amis d'aider des jeunes filles en
quelque sorte qu'ils ont pu deux trois
ans de suite s'y rendre et alors il leur
fallait bien se retrouver le chapeau
enfin adapté d'été des petites
françaises il fallait trouver la tenue
en mai lé temps ils ont été fascinés par
ce que d'une année sur l'autre la reine
très souriante a totalement détendu très
différente de ce qu'on voit
effectivement sur les postes de
télévision et bien se souvenait qu'elle
était dans l école et qu'elle allait
passer dans l'hôtel classe et l on se
disait c'est pas c'est alan les enfants
évidemment les jeunes filles étaient
rares c'est à mai mois enfin est en
réfléchissant se disent aimer le travail
derrière des conseillers essayé
ils se renseigner sur l'école française
et l'ananas dire c'est à nous derrière
une machine de guerre a comme tous les
politiques c'est pour ça que j'ai revu
un bien énorme mais dans ces moments là
elle était beaucoup plus accessible et
détendue mais elle permettait cca n'y
change j'aimerais qu'on dise à un mot de
la série the crown laetitia parce que
quand ça nous parce que vous racontez là
finalement ça nous paraît presque
familier pour ceux qui ont vu cette
série c'est un des gros cartons de la
plateforme netflix avec un budget
colossal 1 410 millions de dollars pour
cette série dont la cinquième saison
parce que moi je suis complètement fan
arrive en novembre donc
accroché à mon fauteuil pour continuer à
avoir cette série est d'ailleurs c'est
assez surprenant parce que il est mise
en scène plusieurs fois cette celui clos
entre le premier ministre et la reine
bien sûr donc d'être de netflix et par
the crane montre un peu alors peut-être
que c'est trés fictionné comme on dit
des retraites imaginée est d'ailleurs
l'auteur a dit qu'il mettait beaucoup de
fictions il assume complètement le fait
de mettre de la fiction que ce ne soit
pas une reproduction
vraiment fidèle à l'histoire mais c'est
vrai qu'on a ces moments un peu
croustillant et 7 series de crohn à
participer encore rendent encore plus
iconiques elizabeth ii et la monarchie
mais elle fait un peu peur à certains
conseillers making a notamment la
prochaine saison de ce monde dans les
normes justement dans
ces années là et puis il y a il y à
aussi on a parlé de l'interaction entre
la reine elizabeth ii et les différents
gouvernements britanniques il y a eu des
moments d'inimitié semble-t-il assez
fort d'après ce que j'ai pu lire les
relations entre la reine et margaret
thatcher était compliquée voire par
difficile en revanche il semble qu'elle
avait de bien meilleures relations avec
john mayer qui a succédé à majeur parce
que là chimie personnel joué beaucoup en
fait le personnage officiel de la reine
et ses fonctions officielles et bien par
moments sans doute devait s'arrêter pour
faire place à des relations entre une
personnalité certes monarque et un
premier ministre une première ministre
quand même arrivé avec le pouvoir qui
est le sien donc on peut imaginer alors
je ne sais pas par rapport à boris
johnson peut-être que le côté un peu
punk de boris johnson lui plaisait pas
ce qu'elle a quand même eu un peu des
punks dans sa famille royale le prince
charles une certaine manière était un
peu punk lui aussi mais on peut imaginer
que quelquefois elle a dû prendre peur
devant certaines initiatives de premier
ministre mais ça c'est l'histoire qui le
dira mais je voudrais qu'on revoie la
photo que convient de nous proposer qu
est la photo de justement de cette
rencontre entre lyss tracé et la reine
elizabeth ce sera peut-être qui sait la
dernière photo officielle de d'elisabeth
2 nous verrons bien n'ouvrons pas le
chapitre de sa succession trop tôt mais
je voudrais qu bruno cautrès il nous
reste quelques minutes dans ce débat on
puisse est évoquée déjà un aspect là la
reine elle n'a pas voulu abdiquer de son
vivant alors que à 96 on aurait pu
imaginer mais même les papes se sont mis
à appliquer de leur vivant à cause de
leur état de santé pourquoi pas la reine
c'est dans ce que ça représente comme
symbole du pouvoir en grande-bretagne et
ailleurs on l'a bien compris en parlant
du commonwealth comment vous l'expliquez
pour plusieurs raisons il ya la fois
quelque chose qui est fondamental c'est
un souverain de ne pas abdiquer c'est
quelque chose qui est le tabou ultime il
ya eu une application au royaume uni qui
a beaucoup marqué effectivement et elle
s'en souvenait
ne se préparait pas
c'est vrai que troisième
ce très très très long règne a eu un
élément
très très dramatique d'une certaine
manière pour charles c'est aussi parce
qu on a vu beaucoup d'opérations un
moment donné où la presse britannique
beaucoup de livres étaient publiés sur
charles à 40 ans puis charles à 50 ans
piégées à 60 ans à chaque fois on dit
bah voilà ça y est c'est le sillage de
la grande maturité il va monter sur le
trône et c'est vrai qu'on une enquête
d'opinion été faite par l'institut ipsos
au royaume-uni demandant quelles étaient
les membres de la famille royale qui
étaient préférés du public britannique
en tête et vivement la reine de très
loin ensuite williams et puis le prince
charles et toi c'est bas dans le
classement en fait et donc c'est
terrible je sais pas si vous pouvez
répondre à la question mais est ce qu'il
ya une dimension de défiance de la part
de la reine vis-à-vis de son fils dans
le fait de ne pas lui avoir transmis le
pouvoir plutôt moi je crois je peux pas
répondre je suis pas dire sa tête mais
je crois que l avait le sens de servir
son pays et elle avait du sens que
autour d'elle ça tenait
elle était un facteur qui permettait à à
ce royaume finalement qui existe encore
de tenir une patte s'éparpiller et elle
avait le sentiment que peut être après
elle ça pourrait se fracturer donc elle
a fait ça plus pour son pays je crois
que par des choses pareilles alors je
vous redonne la parole bono là dessus
puisque vous nous disiez vous aviez
évaluer ce avec des sociologues de vos
collègues ont évalué sa
effectivement pour l'instant la
monarchie restent acceptés par les
britanniques majoritairement
peut-être grâce à l'aura de l'icône
elizabeth 2 qu'est-ce qui se passera
absente sans doute que cette icône
effectivement a
beaucoup beaucoup compté mais je pense
qu'ils ont une dimension encore beaucoup
plus profonde c'était effectivement ça a
été dit tout à l'heure le royaume il ya
aussi des unis maintenant il y avait il
ya deux il ya 2
deux éléments qui unifie la reine et la
monnaie et la reine et l'amener c'est
très important comme symbole de
souveraineté l'abonné aussi ça se pose
là comme un symbole de sol un thé et
c'est vrai que chez les britanniques
l'idée d'avoir d'être aussi mini par une
monnaie fait qu' il n'y avait aucune
chance qu'un jour le royaume uni
rejoigne la zone euro et on sait la
suite de la suite de l'histoire donc je
pense que ce sont ces raisons qui sont
des raisons qui sont assez profonde et
qui touchent à l'histoire de très longue
durée de ce royaume uni merci d'ailleurs
vous aurez derniers mois les à balmoral
en écosse qu'elle se trouve en ce moment
et donc rien que ça c'est quand même un
symbole merci encore à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat bientôt sur
sur public sénat